boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation
I'm your host Alan sake on very pumped
to be talking about I am
self-actualization technology we have
joyous heart joining us on the show
Alan such a pleasure thank you for
having on simulation thank you so pumped
for this me too
oh my gosh you are building literally
that principle that I've been talking
about on the show all time identify your
North Star and pursue it with vigor and
you're like I'm gamifying
ahaha and it's so beautiful I'm so
pumped to showcase this and share with
other people for those that don't know
Joyce's background he is a serial
entrepreneur transformation coach and
the co-founder and CEO of we are which
is an evolved Enterprise incubator and
management company and its flagship
company I am through these enterprises
joyce's focus on developing a socialized
personal development and
self-actualization technology to expand
human consciousness gamifying self
realization and redefine the process of
lifelong learning and you can find the
links in the bio below to play I am calm
as well as I am we are dot X Y Z and
Joyce's website I am joy XY see also
Instagram and Facebook pages joy so
let's start things off with asking you
what are your thoughts on the direction
of our work Oh
meta I love it perfect the direction of
our world is extremely exciting and
inspiring to me I believe we're at a
quantum tipping point and what we're
gonna see emerge over the next few years
to me really lights up my passion
because we're at such a crossroads of
technological innovation I mean our
technocracy is thriving you know what
you're seeing in FinTech and
transportation and really every
different aspect of our life
massive evolutions and now we're at this
and a critical tipping point of
balancing
the the technological innovation with
the evolution of the human experience
that's an individual and a collective
evolution that we're seeing and we're in
the middle of that transformation right
now there's no way out of it it's a
biological imperative really we've
created the perfect sandbox to evolve
our consciousness and grow as a species
and we've created these perceived
challenges and tipping points around us
environmentally socially financially
where there's no other way to go but
through that transition I think there's
going to be a lot of disruption and
that's actually exciting right because
we want to disrupt things that are no
longer working
there's our K ik limited programming and
belief systems and models that may have
worked for a time may have really well
worked for a time and and yet no longer
service and so we're going to see
complete transformation most facets of
our life certainly in most industries
and yeah I mean some people look at it
and they're a little bit apprehensive oh
I got so much change how do I surf this
to me it's really exciting and I feel
that humanity is about to really find
its wings and take flight ok this is so
cool to illustrate it as an actual like
sandbox or container where it's becoming
a biological imperative for us to grow
these wings and take flight to level up
our collective consciousness
individually and collectively to be what
to be more what first of all to be more
embodied right so a lot so I think as a
species we've constantly tried to get
out of the human experience whether it's
through religion trying to like well one
day I'll just be back with God I'll be
home trying to leave in that way a lot
of escapism through media through
substance you know we're constantly
trying to get out to ascend out of the
form and really the Ascension is an
internal process I'm just using that
word for fun but really we're being
called into a higher echelon of
experience into higher vibratory states
of being if everything is really just
light and sound patterning fundamentally
it's vibrations it's geometry it's light
patterns we're being called into more
more complex and cleared
trees and the higher frequency sets and
so you know what's what's really
exciting for me is we can really go
anywhere from here where we've advanced
scientifically and where we're beginning
to advanced spiritually we can it's a
choose-your-own-adventure life and we're
getting to the point where people can
augment their physical bodies we may be
translating consciousness into the
digital verse it's to me there's so many
possibilities and it's limitless and yet
the the channel with all these infinite
pathways that were being pushed toward
is to I believe come into more synergy
as a species so we're here on this rock
hurtling through space there's a billion
of us and we've operated from very
individualistic stance for most of our
remember human history and that's
actually been a severe impediments to
the ecosystemic thrive ability of the
human race and our whole biosphere you
know very self-centered not connected to
the other nodes of humanity activities
and behaviors have led us to certain
paradigms of thinking of business and
industry that have again put us in the
sandbox and pushed us to this position
of growing I feel that you know we're
being pushed into what you could call a
spiritual almost type of transcendence
where we're going to move beyond some of
the limiting functionality that we've
experienced around the planet and
actually step into more of the imprint
that I believe humans have always
carried and you know there's so much
dormant DNA there's so much in our
bodies that has been either never
activated or deactivated through certain
societal and familial spells of
limitation compounded over millennia and
we're at a point of examining all those
things they're all getting on earth and
we're able to look at them really look
at the mirror of what's going on
individually and societally and then
really see what's holding us back and
with all these tipping points we kind of
have to push through so we're like okay
we're we're rising up where the
more of a collective so we can actually
begin exploring space both outer and
inner and let's leave it at that that's
that's for the move answer that question
yeah this this this amount of of dormant
nests in our actual izing ascending
potential that hasn't been fully
realized and and in many ways seems like
around the world is the reason why so
many of us feel some of the mental
health issues or lack of community lack
of love these types of things and to
build technologies that help humans
actualize that unique blueprint that we
have to bring these beautiful fruits to
ourselves or families or community
society at large I'm so pumped to talk
about continue to talk abouts with you
um quickly before we jump into journey
what would you say are some of the key
things today that are important to
unsubscribe to mmm-hmm and on the other
side also to subscribe to beautiful I
love I love looking at both sides one of
the biggest things I believe it's time
to unsubscribe from is that source or
your prime directive your North Star is
anywhere is anywhere outside of yourself
is to bring it back to yourself right
and so on the flipside of that one thing
to subscribe to is realizing that you
are creator and it said you know in
every religious text and every spiritual
text if we're gonna stick to that route
you can also bring it down into quantum
to quantum mechanics of physics but
really any which way you look at it you
are the source of your reality your
unique lens in let's call it a quasi
crystal of consciousness and everything
you're experiencing is a reflection back
to you from what you're transmitting out
you're receiving what you're
transmitting and so to really you allow
yourself more spaciousness from seeking
the external
source to validate what you already are
and really did take more time to dive in
word and realize that your inner verse
is your actual map to the outer verse to
the universe instead of diving to dive
deeper in hmm
that goes hand in hand with shifting
from victim consciousness to create our
consciousness and there's a u-turn
there's a big u-turn to go from to shift
from the habits of things are happening
to me two things are happening for me
and it's of my own design on some level
and my subconscious in my higher
consciousness
I'm architecting or agreeing to
experiences relationships you know life
dynamics to allow me to grow versus oh
this is like this is happening to me how
could someone do this to me really
realizing internalizing this is a gift
I'm so grateful I created this
experience for myself to go through
whatever fire I'm going to transform
whatever is no longer working those to
me are really key
I also unsubscribing from you know base
level consciousness media most of the
media were saturated and is very focused
on stimulating fight-or-flight you know
we're over our Drina 'ls are being
completely depleted because we're
subscribing to media mainstream news
outlets a lot of mainstream vid movies
and even online content that is really
reinforcing negative limiting patterns
and beliefs so much violence right so
much fear and shame and doubt you're
feeding that to yourself right it's just
the same thing as putting food in your
body you're taking in those frequencies
you're taking those images and those
frames and they're layering into your
consciousness so unsubscribe as much as
you can from the sources of information
that really aren't creating the reality
you want if you're looking at a horror
movie is that the world you want to live
in no so why are you subscribing to that
and telling your subconscious that's a
reality and allowing that to be a
permission slip in your life on the
inverse subscribe to things like
simulations subscribe to things that are
enriching your spirit and expanding your
mind and open
your heart and and the last to go along
with that since we're already on that
subject is looking at what you're
putting in your body so we're talking
about media also really look at the food
you're putting in your body unsubscribe
from corporations that's their only
focused on the bottom line they're
focused on providing you the base level
nutritional if even that value to allow
you to feel full those channels of its
in pharmaceuticals it's in food but
really like really be attentive to what
you're taking in your body and stop
subscribing any things that don't have
your best interests in mind that are
really only looking at shareholder value
and do really don't care about your
health and well-being whoa
epic so the unsubscribe to believing
that the North Star lies with exogenous
substances that the North Star is
endogenous is within us and then to be
able to pursue that divinely unsubscribe
I love how you talked about the video or
what we've taken as input like layers as
frames into our consciousness when you
like think about it that way then it's
like do you really want those frames to
be layered in and impact who you are and
that's a really good way put in the same
thing with food as well
yeah unsubscribe from self-dealing
institutions fake foods fake news fake
physicians fake teachers all these types
of things I love that that was great and
those are and subscribed to this North
Star from being within media that helps
you get to that point of actualization
let's talk about the journey Joyce who
were you growing up that got you
interested in what you care about today
well to my detriment and and to my great
benefit I was a rebel so I tested every
boundary I didn't take anything at face
value just because someone was older or
they had credentials and they were
teacher police officer just because they
were telling me something I really felt
into is this right is this kind does it
make sense does it resonate does it
actually feel
right because I'm not just gonna take it
at face value because you say so so I
pushed a lot of boundaries played with a
lot of dimensions peered under
everything look through every doorway
and thankfully I had parents that really
supported that my mother is a medical
doctor who realized that mainstream
modern medicine is great if you're
having an emergency and pretty much for
nothing else it's absolutely the
opposite of self-care and preventive
medicine so she went from being an MD to
an ende and basically stepped almost
into shamanism from there my father
just to keep the play on the shaman as
it was basically a corporate shaman he
would never call himself that he was
talking about core why discovering her
core purpose and core why way before
simon Sinek
he was the first one really in the
corporate sphere talking about emotional
literacy and talking about how most of
the top and societal issues are related
to them but they're almost none of them
are IQ based they're all EQ based all
the big issues that companies have with
their employees what they're looking for
all the breakdowns amongst team dynamics
are EQ based so you talked so he really
figured out how to bridge the heart mind
gap how to bridge EQ and IQ that's his
company q IQ hmm and what a combo for
parents damn
very blessed very blessed one the cosmic
lottery there and so I grew up saturated
in the work of my parents which was all
around
holistic frameworks around wellness
psychologically spiritually mentally
physically you know my father also was
very deep in integrity courage
developing your courage quotient
identifying the different types of
courage like the courage to dream and
put forth that dream a lot of people
have that courage don't have the courage
to see current reality and vice versa so
identifying your courage quotient so I
grew up in that and that really inspired
me particularly as I came out in the
world and from such a loving open
supportive household to see the stark
contrast with so many of the fit my
friends families and just in the greater
world it well did two things ultimately
it inspired me to step into the work I'm
doing now and really devote my life to
socio-economic enrichment and figuring
out what the core levers are to help as
many human beings as possible feel that
love feel that joy feel that
authenticity
feel that empowerment in claiming their
own path because my parents really were
open with me uh I'm not going to school
this week I'm done with it they're like
what are you gonna learn about what are
you passionate about go learn about and
present to us at the end of the week
yeah so they were really open with me
what that did though being in such an
incredible bubble of consciousness then
going out in the greater world it
created a lot of conflict within within
me it developed I developed a lot of
depression anger in my teenage years at
the angst of the human condition you
know feeling the miracle of this life
feeling how precious it is right
Einstein said either everything's a
miracle or nothing else you have two
ways of looking at it and so I grew up
in everything's a miracle and we're so
blessed and then I saw the exact
opposite modeled so many ways to me from
all the media from interactions that
other people were having with each other
and so that put me in a tailspin you
know in full transparency it put me into
substance there's nothing hard but you
know mycelial consciousness and in
cannabis and things to figure out how to
modulate what I was feeling because I
was so I was almost overwhelmed by the
amount of pain and suffering and
disconnection that I was experiencing
with humans within themselves amongst
them amongst themselves and
communication and with the planet and
how they were treating you know
everything around them so that journey
you know that led me to explore a lot of
different realms I worked with a lot of
different shamans from different
lineages from around the world thanks to
my mother and it was I'm lucky I made it
through honestly it was a very tough
period I kept sending out signals to the
universe I said I don't know why I chose
to be here or why I was sent here but
I'm ready to go like this is I don't
know what's happening this is a weird
thing to be a 1314 year old having these
dialogues you know I was like I I don't
know how to relate here I think this
race is really juvenile and I don't know
what to do this was me as a juvenile and
the only way I could interpret the
reality around me the way that was
answered was when I left home I moved to
Colorado I had a series leading up to
this to the shift at a series of very
life-altering experiences that
culminated in me a few months after I
moved to Colorado having my first
near-death experience I stopped
breathing for 12 minutes
scare the crap out of my friends we're
in the woods I just fell over
face-planted didn't breathe for 12
minutes they tried to resuscitate me
eventually they're like he's gone
so all they could do is go into
meditation they didn't know what else to
do we're in the middle of nowhere that
12 minutes for me was timeless it was it
was pure bliss really hard to
contextualise into words and I won't
even I won't go too deep into it but for
the sake of the simulation we'll just
touch on you know essentially I lifted
out could see reality as a holographic
layer could see the earthgrid that I was
on could see my body very quickly
started flowing through different time
scapes and seeing different realities
and something my consciousness would
know it's like oh Babylon Oh Egypt and I
but I was seeing it almost have you ever
seen Alex gray painting like like an
energetic grid there wasn't the outer
shell on it just the energetic grid and
I surfed through these realities for
what felt like forever and all of a
sudden I was in this white undulating
field infinite in every direction with
these golden pearls connected by
strength all connected this grid of gold
and pearls infinite in every direction
every single one representing a lifetime
and every one the focus on would become
the center of this undulating grid and I
went in and actually experienced
multiple lifetimes not living out a
whole lifetime but going in and having
actual and like embodied experiences and
lifetimes and then kept and then I would
be back in this grid and at a certain
point this is knowing it was a resonance
it was a voice but there was but you're
in a place that's voiceless this this
knowing that that vibrated in said
you're going into form mmm you're going
back into a lifetime and I said
wonderful the lifetime I've been in was
still a memory because it was recent but
it wasn't it wasn't anymore like I I
didn't miss it and I wasn't expecting to
go back to it and so then everything
spiraled like this whole engineering
field spiraled into light and scared my
friends because my arms shut up and I
remember everything was the highest tone
and pure white light and then slowly
everything filtered in
and everything at the reset you know
here it was like hands sky trees earth
body joyous and had to reset and had to
like remember who who I was with it took
me a couple weeks to really really from
that experience but that was the first
of a series of major experiences that
pushed me through through certain
dimensions of the simulation and that
what that particular experience did for
me was it allowed me to have zero fear
of transition or what people call death
of leaving this avatar zero fear yeah
which is permeated to this day it's
cellular II encoded and more importantly
for the first time since I'd been maybe
12 made me so enthralled and joyful and
inspired to be alive and so grateful for
this opportunity to be an individual and
have such a distinct separation between
us as individuals instead of kind of
this kind of blurred energy like we're
really distinct and wow I can I have
human emotion well I stubbed my toe that
hurts ah it's so cool I get to feel that
so totally reorient in my whole my whole
relationship with reality whoa
so then this takes us to when you were
wondering about that this kind of like
all these different like why are you
here the feeling of why you were here
and and what this world was like and
maybe what was my point of experiencing
all of this world and then you the the
NDE that you had just that putting those
words to it those so beautiful that
story and it's
I'm just even trying to conceptualize
where you were and how you were feeling
is so cool for me to do that and lift
through that vicariously and and and and
then when when you're when you're did
when you're seeing all them being off
feeling all that it then you get to this
to the rim buddy
come back and it clicks that everything
that we can feel and experience here is
gorgeous yeah yeah and and and the and
the deepest most intense experience of
her life are the greatest gifts and
you're like wow okay this is this too
shall pass
even if I play this out for a lifetime
even if I don't choose to dive in and
transmute this which I actively do
transmute anything I come across as a
block but even if I choose to fantastic
because it's the blink of an eye for the
I am consciousness that that's
pretending to be me right and that that
experience was was the it was the cosmic
hall pass it was like okay everything's
okay it's okay see it's all right it's
all perfect and then I had experiences
after that including hope other
attendees that allowed me a deeper that
was more just like take it all in then I
was actually getting direct avatar
reflections and direct beings basically
giving me feedback loops as to why I was
here so so the journey continued and and
you know basically in several other
experiences I was reminded by other
beings that are not in bodies quasi
physical beyond physicality that of why
I was here why I chose to sign up of how
great of an honor it was to be on earth
of how many infinite souls want to be
here of how long that waiting list is to
embody here and and of the really big
mission we all have a big mission
everyone does and everybody's a genius
but if you try to teach a fish to climb
a tree all spent his whole life thinking
is stupid as well but Einstein also said
and so you know it was a beautiful gift
to have the universe so strongly respond
to my deep calling and yearning and
intentions and prayer you know however
you want to verbalize that my my output
to have the direct interface a
reflection of here this is why you're
here
let's let's show you and what that
showed me was I'm here as a social
architect to help reinvent certain
paradigms of human relationship and
that's both in community building
community design and building I was in
the regenerative community space for
quite a while and that's something I'm
very passionate about is redesigning
urban escapes to be truly regenerative
which is as much as you're depleting
you're then replenishing and what I saw
clearly in some of these experiences but
then became much clearer as I was
working in building physical communities
was that it wasn't the physical
architecture the clean radiant free
energy technologies the advanced food
and water systems the bio architecture
that's all easy it's all here whether or
not it's fully out in the open yet you
know that's also part of what I believe
is emergent in our world in the next
decade which is going to you know change
everything it was the social
architecture it was the modelling on
health and wellness and most importantly
education and what it really came to me
was that the way we trained ourselves to
be fundamentally is our reality where
we're programming the compile aaja
computers that we are with the scripts
for what runs our reality and then our
reality can only offer us that which
we're programming it to offer us and so
I realized as I looked at the start
diving in the statistics on education
because I had had a very rough time in
education I tried everything I was
home-schooled public private did
everything just trying to take you know
see what would work and I found great
pieces and different methodologies but
none of them quite worked and it was
there were several pieces one is the
environment itself the environments are
not conducive to actually
yeah to to being inspired to being
empowered to being being present I mean
your average school building is your
under these harsh Flushing lights and
it's really uncomfortable chairs this
little desk sitting for hours a day
eating crappy food of the cafeteria it's
not conducive to you actually optimizing
your creativity and being excited to be
there retaining that information and
then it was also the content that was
being taught and how the content was
being taught yeah and the fact that the
whole thing was designed we're basically
monocropping humans we know that doesn't
work with plants it doesn't work with
humans there really wasn't particularly
in the formative years at least up until
college for most people and education
around the world it there is no
choose-your-own-adventure there is no
personal development or personal
discovery it's this is the way to do it
you have to do it this way and this time
or you're gonna fail and and I realized
that we were creating a ton of blocks
for ourselves we're really limiting our
human potential by the way we train
ourselves to be and so that is something
that after being shown it for several
years I chose the step fully into and
and devote myself as part of the
regenerative economic movement as part
of a singularity that we're approaching
2 in terms of spirituality in science
you know technology and biology was the
juxtaposition of the systems frameworks
products technologies related to
evolving human learning systems and
personal development in a sense you were
carrying around this mentality with you
after your indian through the next steps
of your life we were just looking around
you and seeing all the things that you
could upgrade and update and make it
more
holistic and inspiring and and make the
processes better for self and collective
actualization I love that mentality we
talk a lot about having that mentality
when you walk through the world and then
also just this you're so right about the
lack in activation of this unique North
Star that's within every single person
because it is just become in its sense
just the most standardized monoculture
of Education across the planet okay now
then where did the I am come from is
this kind of the story that led you to
be like okay I need to create and
co-create this with other people what I
am is that fills that void that makes it
fun for me to figure out what my North
Stars and pursue it in a gamified way
yes so so for me the transition was I
was working on community on land
projects so the last one that I did with
my beloved sandy and a good friend of
mine was up in Oregon it was a thousand
acre ranch called the new paradigm ranch
as a showcase Center for new types of
social architecture and physical
technologies the transition was I
realized I wanted a bigger scale ability
factor I wanted a bigger ripple of
impact and that building land based
centers is very important and I'm so
grateful the people who are doing that
to create examples for existing urban
escapes on how to begin to redefine
redesign and retool what's already there
to make it work better to make it work
better for people and for the planet so
there's actually a carrying capacity to
continue but I realized for me the
calling was much larger systemic yeah
much larger systemic yeah like like what
are the what are the the platforms and
protocols that are going to allow tens
of millions hundreds of millions of
people to quickly on board into aligning
with their North Star and then building
those different
so that future that we want to live in
yes I like that that that's a similar
mentality that I carry in that I think a
lot of people are trying to figure out
is like one color on the color wheel is
to do the the 1000 acre plot of land or
to do like a family or whatever it is
and there's like another color on the
color wheel which is to get something
out to billions of people that enables
them to express their own creative
building of a future that that like
compounds in a sense of you get it out
to that many people and then they start
building in a war awakened way yeah and
well and what I only figured is is that
when you can do that it's actually much
more effective because a lot of the I
believe that a lot of the big challenges
humankind is facing can all stem back to
that lack of human development of the
lack of authenticity if you're not
really passionate I mean going the
statistics about how many people are
disengaged in their work don't love
their life are unhappy it's kind of
astounding how can you show up for your
community really how can you show up for
a business partner or or an intimate
partner how can you show up for the
planet you can't because you're not even
showing up for yourself and so you're
constantly living in the state of like
anxiety and like this angst even behind
the scenes you everything might be good
I'm just gonna go to the bar tonight
everything's great but you you're you're
not clearing this lens so how are you
gonna see what's clearly in front of you
even offer assistance to care or even if
you care to even be able to offer
something that's really valuable to that
person or situation if you're not even
doing that for yourself so I started to
I started building a platform and a
couple months into that is when I
connected with my partner Lucien Patel
Lucien you know I've been using the I am
framework for quite a while it just as a
reference point in consciousness because
I am is a very powerful Proclamation
yeah it's the Trinity I am right so UT
swine so so you have the the masculine
and the feminine principle and then the
one and so you have also like you can
like Holy Father mother
child you can view at different ways but
it's the trying and I am is a reference
point in consciousness so it's like
you're putting in a command in the in
the in the computer in the simulation I
am and then the whole simulation goes
what what are you and whatever follows
that is true right so we're always
spelling
we're spelling we're casting spells
we're programming and some spells are
master spells I am as a master spell
it's been medically ingrained for
millennia and it's just it's the
ultimate affirmation I am prosperous I
am loving I am father and the universe
is able to reflect and respond to that
so it's a declaration of embodiment and
of consciousness and so it's very
important Lucianne independently
channeled I am and we are on top of a
mountain he had a very clear download he
was running a nonprofit called game desk
at the time creating interactive
learning technologies mainly for middle
schoolers but for K through 12 education
yeah and making the process of learning
really fun experience oh yeah and he
preached in juxtaposition areas like
this is really cool like we're having a
lot of fun here we're even doing you
know emotional and treatment biofeedback
games we're now kids in LA don't have to
go to detention they're going and
learning how to modulate their their
anger and their frustration through a
game and all kinds of really fun
technologies and incredible
breakthroughs and he was like this isn't
enough we're still we're still taking
mainly what's here this common core yeah
and making it really fun and increasing
pre and post you know like oh look
they're learning it better it's deeper
they're retaining it longer but it's
still limited where's the communication
where's the compassion the emotional
literacy the courage the the personal
development is lacking and so he was on
a deep soul soul journey a Vision Quest
if you will what's next how do I really
take my background as a filmmaker as a
professor and as an interactive
technologist and and create something
that is actually going to turn the tide
in the academic world which has a lot of
impedances that evolution due to the
bureaucracy and economics
with education and what came in very
clear like an ND like a ND experience
like so strong and clear where's first
time actually meeting other beings yeah
was you are to build i am and we are and
he got a glimmer of what that was very
shortly thereafter he started putting he
started everything in his life he
started orienting everything in his work
towards this north star yes very surely
thereafter the universe brought us
together and i shared with him when i
was what i was working on he said i
don't know if this is good great or a
complete conflict of interest but we're
working we want to do the same thing
yeah and I said great because I'm about
the results I'm about the transformation
of human consciousness I don't give a
crap about what the brand is
I really don't I'll put that aside I
will join you
we ended up becoming 50/50 partners but
I didn't even care about that like we
became you know equal co-creators in the
construct that he had originally
channeled but we had the same background
information we were both on the same
mission the same North Star and I said I
see your background I see your passion I
love this branding because I already
work with this consciousness and that's
all of it the I am a tuning Who I am and
then the we are in the sinner key and so
that journey started three years ago
when we when we first came together and
we played around for a while and
consciousness and then began to take the
framework and test it in different
iterative analog experiences first with
middle schoolers and then as we realized
we were gonna build a larger social
architectural framework than just
something nuanced for K through 12
although there's a whole white-label
aspect to bring it back particularly
into the K through 12 sandbox was we
evolved from working with middle scores
to really work with people from all
different socioeconomic backgrounds all
different demographics and and for us it
was very important before we jumped into
this is a first for either him or I and
just kind of jumping right into building
something we're like we're not gonna
build a technology until we understand
the technology because this is it this
is something that already exists in the
simulation this already exists in the
hologram of consciousness and we're just
building a physical access port or
interface for what's already happened
and we really need to understand that if
we're gonna build life match algorithms
that are connecting people to the core
of who they are to their North Star and
helping them with socialized supports to
develop who they are and then connect
them to people and experiences that are
most aligned with who they are we've got
to be really accurate so it's not just
taking people on you know random detours
in their life like how do we really
build an interface that can operate as
kind of a meta intuitive intelligence
that's there to support and guide you
through your personal growth journey
where it still retains that unique
creative sovereignty and
choose-your-own-adventure where we're
not telling you what to do we're where
the system is offering you options that
are most aligned with who you are and
we'll go into how we actually determine
what that is and and it's hold does its
whole design it's not to extract value
from you but to provide the most value
how can we support you in fully
embodying who you are your unique value
and gifts are you having fun and feeling
supported the whole way and you're able
to step in and share that value with the
world and actually that is your
vocational path rather than well no I
can't be a I can't be an artist I need
to be a lawyer [ __ ] absolutely
you're an artist you could be a lawyer
and an artist but we want to support you
in whatever you're most passionate about
and I say we as the collective and the
interface is supporting that we want to
support you in really being the whole
you the fully authentic you because
that's the greatest gift to yourself and
to all of us because if you're not in
that space we're all suffering from it
and so that was that was the impetus for
I am yeah didn't you she she envisioned
the ocean is the other co-founder of
this Wow Wow Lucian's background - so
interesting with what he was doing with
the middle schoolers engaging them more
experientially and learn
and then how you come in also with such
a deep drive for transforming
consciousness and transforming education
and the Northstar journey and how
aligned those two were when you guys met
and that seems like a very cool divine
synergy now now as we do I am and talk
about this let's actually let's actually
pull up some of the stuff that we have
to show throughout so okay so explain
some of this you kind of get a bit of on
this on the disconnected feeling and
unfulfilled meant these were the numbers
that you were talking about yeah Center
are working in jobs that they disliked
and disengaged in yeah and then I love
what we're gonna show next which is what
the engagement platform looks like the
self actualization technology looks like
beyond let's walk through is beautiful
so really you know the the top end issue
is people are fundamentally most people
are disconnected from their core sense
of self from their core value their core
potential their core purpose their core
passions and you can see that explicitly
in some of these statistics so you know
what we put here is the problem is
people are most people are disconnected
and fulfilling their lives in a general
sense and they're not monetizing what
they love and they don't have any
interface for sense making around their
self discovery and their self growth and
from that place meaning meaningful human
interaction with aligned peers and
mentors who can support them and showing
them the most opportune places for
social value exchange to receive value
and to share the value they are you know
statistically the reason we talk about
people being disconnected and
unfulfilled and not Amanat and not
feeling that they can monetize who they
are and what they love and then they
have to go do something else
other than who they are to make money is
you have 67 percent of people in this
country who've been you know nationwide
polls that state that they're unhappy
that's really sad I mean that's
depressing
you like 67 percent of people and that's
about the same it's it's it's it's about
the same globally so you've got close to
70% of people around the world
classifying themselves as unhappy and
you have over 300 million people
depressed with are diagnosed with
chronic depression which is a societal
issue it's not most people really aren't
fundamentally
pressed it's the fact that they're in an
echo chamber that doesn't work like this
is not right I'm I'm not being authentic
I'm not really living my potential and
so and but everyone's telling me this is
normal
I'm doing something I hate and now I'm
just gonna suppress and repress and numb
and whatever I'm you do and and then you
see that moving forward 80 it's 85% of
people around the world it's a little
bit lower in the states state that
they're in jobs that they dislike and
are disengaged in what does that do for
human productivity and creativity think
about what that does for the workplace
for innovation and what does that do for
the human spirit like how much are we
atrophying our creative potential and
our brilliance to live into a
dysfunctional archaic social modeling
system that doesn't work it doesn't work
right and so that's the that's the top
end issue is there's no platformer
interface for sense making who you are
and supporting you in Sochi and
developing who you are rewarding you for
developing who you will know connecting
you to the most alliance supports and
people so that you can actualize who you
are and monetize all the aspects that
you have to offer the world I'm I'm
interested to know how you figure this
out that you've you help people figure
out who they are you help them take
their beautiful creative journey along
the path of knowing themselves and
getting to their North Star and there
are support systems along the way of
connecting with other people that help
you on your journey you help them on
their journey I really want to know how
you like identify these aspects yeah of
me like let's take me for example how do
you would you know what we're divorced
are is and how would you I wouldn't you
would okay so the interface is designed
to allow you to have to play the game of
figuring that out so we have our own
unique
I am blueprint or self mapping system
and a part of that system is a
swipe-based
at least on the mobile app a swipe-based
interface for selecting attributes
you're most interested in like this like
this so this so you have different
imagine decks of of virtue and values
cards of skill cards of life blocks or
life challenge cards rience you're able
to go through these cards you tap their
on courage it's not going to work in the
deck but if I were to tap on curves I
can flip over Oh - okay so it's swiping
yes or no but also clicking yeah so
there's so so if I tap on it it's gonna
flip over it's gonna show me the most
universal definition of what in this
case courage is it's going to show me
best practices and tips some imagery
just real quick at a glance what is this
if I don't know if you delight oh and
then I can choose I can swipe into is
that something that we're actually gonna
do it to the four quadrants so is this
something that I have mastery in is this
something that I'm developing is this
something I'm seeking to develop or
seeking supporting or is this something
I'm not really interested in and then
different sliders to be able to to say
look let's break that apart so what's
your so if you say I have something I'm
mastery and then it's gonna break down a
thing well is that across the board or
let's let's break out some some sliders
here so category subcategory of math
courage in the workplace you know
courage with family courage with friends
right so there's different types of
courage some people are very courageous
home and I courageous in the workplace
and vice versa so then we're a lot of
people to get deeper in the granularity
of that after you go through the self
selection process which is dynamic you
can go back to it at any time and it's
going to get increasingly more
intelligent as to which cards to show
you first based on who it knows you to
be based on your actions in the system
based on community reflections and some
of the other integrated third party self
mapping or persona mapping systems were
integrating with you building a
psychometric profile for the user based
on their them swiping into mastery or
seeking or developing or not interested
it's on these skill cards yeah and
virtue cards in light box so her choo
cards in life block yeah so okay yeah
you may show a card about like issues
with family or issues with some other
trauma or exactly and then I'll put
myself in the you know in those
quadrants Rogers exactly whoa and so
what this does is ultimately we there's
not there's no I'm not gonna show your
screen here that that will exemplify
this but ultimately what it creates is a
a map so we have a GPS for our car why
don't we have one for our soul so it
creates a map for your inner verse if
you will it creates a map of you a
dynamic map that you're able to interact
with to see the constellations of what
is here's the core of you and then
what's closest in in terms of skills and
virtues in terms of what's most
cultivated most mastered most embodied
to developing to still on the periphery
like I want to develop it is still a
weakness to so you actually have a map
and view a dynamically shifting map of
who you are and share that with other
people so at a glance to be like this is
who I am to so this is my mastery these
are things I've mastered these are the
things I'm developing my gosh original
place is like a very supportive that we
have for this is like a resume oh we're
like so like that it's so static we're
like a like a one-minute video about
like what someone is but like a
beautiful well illustrated map of who I
am based on like my core values and
principles at the center yeah and then
about some more outside is like what I'm
developing what I'm like seeking to
develop as a skillset what like what I'm
not to like so then we can then so
there's a couple things here first is I
love this GPS for the North Star that's
huge for the car but not for the sole I
love that and also then there's this
like overlay process right of like
taking joyous is and looking at it with
or ease or Sansa seeing like okay well
how do they relate where are there's no
connect is there's no connections not
good fit or maybe there are some really
important connections where one person
can teach another person some skills
yeah that type of thing you own the data
yeah sue this parts so interesting as
well so you have walk us down with some
of those avenues yeah absolutely so
let's hop over here so knowing yourself
is very important alright that's the
first part know thyself yes you listen
now take that age old aphorism and
socialize it
so how do we socialize personal
development flip the script from
self-help that we help and create that's
what people are yearning for if you look
at the trends Millennials are spending
twice the amount of baby boomers and
gen-x combined and personal development
and we're looking at people hacking
existing social platforms trying to find
a way to to talk about deep human issues
around you know deep deep personal
development human growth issues and it's
very limited that interface those
interfaces are not designed Facebook's
not designed for those types of
communications you have people
commenting and commenting and comedy
it's it's really it's not designed for
but people want it yeah so you're seeing
what we're seeing
by analyzing what's happening on social
media platforms and then looking at
trends and the three point seven
trillion our wellness industry it are
all these signals of a shift where
self-improvement is becoming mainstream
it's becoming socialized so we're really
looking to create the first social
platform to meet that market demand so
here we get into socialized personally
myself it's so social yeah yeah it's key
right because it's the I am in that we
are you need the reflection you want the
reflection you I want to be able offer
my gifts to you for whatever type of
exchange monetary direct value exchange
there's different ways of exchanging
within the platform and also to support
me even if it's just the reflection as
an accountability coach or just someone
saying yeah great job you up leveled
your an entrepreneurship I see that you
reach level 2 in your quest awesome just
to have those reflections and everything
today you see it's great things
teachable who to may who to me there's a
lot of great content creation platforms
that are allowing people to take their
mastery with no technical skill sets
whatsoever and translate that into
curricular pathways online but there
have no social functionality there's no
analytics dashboard to sense make or
track your your development across your
different trajectories of what you
regarding there's no social
functionality yeah so we need that sense
making apparatus for driving ourselves
towards the North Star and the
socialized aspect
to know who these nodes are that we can
connect with the Maximizer success to
get there it's key especially because
because in the way that our world works
right now it can be a very lonely path
to identify and more importantly to
actively embody and express your North
Star you because there's so many
reflections from your family from people
are like don't don't work on that maybe
this is what you need to focus on right
this is the goal this is me come this is
your million dollar a year career you
need to go this way and so it can be
lonely and isolating and so you want to
have peer groups and mentor groups that
can support you in that process and so
I'm gonna circle back to what you talked
about but ok you know I just want it for
the continuity of the flow so each
attribute confidence entrepreneurship
algebra you know as this as the system
really becomes diverse each attribute
has its own wall so that's an evergreen
content feat of all the quests content
post everything related to that
attribute to confidence to whatever that
act and this in this in this example
confident and that's not your level of
his number twos like you're saying yeah
so that's your level and so then you see
on the right well yet to the right side
of the screen
you see so you there's an exploration
wall and then there's the quest wall so
you can actually activate a quest I'm
questing in the confidence I'm choosing
to embody and master confidence or
whatever that attribute is okay and then
you're amping this this is where it gets
really fun and game fight because we're
actually creating a token economy where
you'll actually be reward incentivized
for completing quests so you're you're
benefiting and you're you're you're
earning something to upgrade your
digital avatar into to exchange for
services and premium content within the
system yeah for self growth so it's like
thank you for becoming the best version
of you possible we're gonna reward you
for 2007 exactly inside and you and you
can track you can track your development
in your progression how much time how
many challenges how many things you've
completed along that trajectory and who
you've connected with along the way so
in each quest pathway there's individual
activities and and and content practices
there's partner and there's small small
and large group and we're also the work
it's really fun is
blending this into the physical so we
already see this list layering as
technology and biology we are beginning
to meet in so many interesting ways we'd
really do need to we do need to balance
the BI the biological quotient with the
AI right we need to balance those
quotients and they are coming into
harmonization or they're seeking to
which is a kind of emergence of a new
type they're new life forms are
basically emerging through technology
when we consider artificial intelligence
and human consciousness and human
biology and what's what's happening it's
getting really interesting and kind of
like kind of very superluminal at the
way things are ideally our biometric
states are constantly being fed to
predict the development of pathologies
and then us to be able to take
actionable steps similarly to North Star
growth with our passions exactly as our
North Star gross with our with our
biology for our health our exercises
that sleep these types of things yes it
did that that's an interesting smash
team and the way we want to meet that is
this platform one of our KPIs is
actually to increase the frequency and
depth of meaningful in-person connection
and value exchange and so we're using
geo proximal alerting and moving into
mobile AR and the beta and beyond all
the way building towards wearables to
lower the barriers of screen time
between human connections so there's
bonus points and certain quests levels
that you can only complete by having
live experiences right yeah you don't
have to meet a specific person but some
experiences like you might want to
complete a mastery level challenge
course and it might require you to to
flashmob confidence in a park it might
require you to meet other people yeah
that's a great I like I love that
example for mastery can you flash mob in
a park yeah for comfort confidence yes
right we can we can do that with
anything yeah and then this is self
reporting or how would you know what
other people report that Allen complete
this task of well there's different ways
of that so there's different there's
different metrics for how it's reported
there is self reporting and that's but
that also includes geo proximal tagging
was this person actually there so that
so if you're reporting that something's
happen we can this
system can say okay well gee
approximately they were there is also
prompts to upload videos to upload
photos ok other people can give
reflections and that's incentivized so
we're finding a way of cool limiting bad
actors because really no one wins in the
game of self-actualization my cheating
achieve yet we're giving a lot of
different entry points for data to
really coordinate was this person there
did they do this thing
and so there's community reflection
there's also self reflection then
there's just the technology being able
to to sit so it's check were they there
did they do that thing okay and then
let's talk about the the data side of
things so then we have this beautiful
self-actualization graph that we get to
see this data visualization of ourselves
how it overlays with others as we go and
evolve our skill sets and then rather
than the way that the current it's so
it's so primordial the way that we have
IT world's set up right now in terms of
data ownership being siloed data not
being like portable or a readable across
chain echo chambers or silos and
ownership not getting like rewarded for
ownership so tell us about your strategy
with data beautiful so our entire model
is not based on ad revenue which is the
that being the business model creates a
very certain ecosystem it creates a very
extractive model where people like it's
free well it's not free at all and every
bit every aspect about who you are and
all everything all your creativity all
of your IP that you're putting there is
now a copy that is now owned by another
entity and they're doing whatever they
want with it
and really the whole thing is sell to
the highest bidder and sell you products
that we think you like so it's again
consumeristic it's not focused on the
economy that's emerging which is the
experiential economy the economy of
experiences is focused on a very
transactional product based economy to
me what we're moving into is that
presence is the ultimate product
embodiment is the one true value versus
moving out of economy
if you're not enough you need these
things so we're surrounded by things we
don't even really want we're spending
money on things we don't want most the
product life cycle mo things it ends up
in a landfill within six months most
things that we buy so those systems are
built on extracting who you are and then
selling you to the highest bidder
that's not our model at all you own your
data in the ecosystem of course the the
intelligence the the heart brain AI and
algorithms running the system need to
have access to your profile to best can
match make you to the right content
content pathways people and experiences
but ultimately you own that data you
could always revoke those permissions
the system would be a little more blind
and being able to offer you things that
were really targeted for you but rather
than selling you anything
the system is focused on matching you
yeah let's focus on matching you to
experiences opportunities people and
content and then I thought of me a
monthly so it's a freemium model at
least at its current iteration I can't
promise what it'll be when we actually
release in nineteen months is probably
around the time will actually release
right now we're focusing on a freemium
model and the average subscription to
your coming in it as $9.99 super easy
it's like what you pay for Spotify
anything else so cheap and then we have
a we have a transactional model as well
so for content creators so we're
bringing in we're bringing in experts in
the different dominions that we're
launching with but we're launching
whether the most universally relevant
skills virtues and life blocks right so
if you look at the top relevant skills
virtues and life blocks right or
challenges anyone look at that which is
okay yeah we chose traits of challenges
as an easier one to play with but like
scarcity self-worth doubt there's if you
look at the top 15 anyone in the world
is dealing with multiple of those across
each of those categories same thing with
skill sets okay what are the top things
that are a breakdown between human
connection and the top things that
companies are really looking for
similarly the list of all the things
companies are looking for that are not
being training school you've got
communication collaboration design
thinking so so we're launching the most
university relevant that are applicable
no matter what you're doing
and then we're building it and then as
we move into it'll be launching the
Alpha but also in the beta was going to
become really active we're building a
content creation ecosystem so it becomes
an open source platform in a sense we
reach where individuals can become
validated and verified and begin to
create their own content in their own
content pathways within the system oh
cool and and so circling back you know
those launching content pathways as like
a master classes type thing totally yeah
except except socialized with a really
robust analytics dashboard and and
bringing it into the physical so you
know getting you have like your
interface here for tracking for
connecting matchmaking and then how do I
bring that out and actually apply that
to this to this avatar I'm in this video
game so let's see circling back so going
with the the launching content pathways
and the well train of thought stem
extreme consciousness will I think was
something good that you mentioned was
that we have so it's gonna be end of
2020 issues when you're looking at a
petal on and then what about now just
speak about now like um this is being
currently is it's in the hands of young
people like no no no
so but what Yushin built was prior to
prior yes and so then you're okay so
then yet speak about like what the
testing cycles are like right now and
sure what we're we're actually early in
our MVP cycle because we're looking at
really building a landmark technology
experience so all the functionality that
we're talking about here including the
Geo proximal alerting and a robust quest
system time it's a lot of text that it's
it's a big text design stack as a lot of
our R&D particularly for what we're
building into with fillet our
functionality and also with the
synthesis of some of the other
integrated system percent of mapping
systems that have better inform the
algorithms as to who you are so we're
looking at weaving in astrology gene
keys India Graham there's different
profiling systems that were weaving in
we've already been talking with the
creators of some of these systems yeah
to really enhance
the ability for the system to really
know who you are you know give you the
best the best of life it's not just
about me submitting my own into each
quadrant but it's also about my birthday
birth time birth location exactly
also just maybe I yes'm it might you
know maybe maybe in the future maybe
absolutely maybe and and and those
things can happen biofeedback sensor
feedback you know oh cool beat it would
be amazing that would be so blow that
you we were listen we're recently
learning from Nicholas Christakis that
there is a certain portion of our genome
that has a lot of variation and that
portion of the genome is why we have
such great variation in our faces which
is like our unique identifiers as our
face until I can't see it people who the
person like like or co-create with or is
your partner the other type of stuff so
how cool would it be to be able to like
map North Stars with genetic sequence
variations then I would be really
interested I'd be super so like that
yeah well there's a lot of fun places to
take it yeah and again you know that
would be the reason we can go that route
I mean ultimately this will be the
greatest compendium and library of human
development on the planet yeah and we
can do that because whether or not it's
fully distributed which we're playing
with to see where blockchain can hold
this we've been in explorations with
hollow chain and and different they've
been looking at different protocol
layers that we can build on whether or
not it's distributed either way it has
full data integrity individuals on their
data and so from that place people as
they begin to really learn and trust the
brand you know and like really really
feel what it is that we're bringing
forth they're able to trust it and say
okay I can give it biofeedback from
sensors liking I can put my genetic data
in there I can have my purse because I
own this this is my dashboard to Who I
am and I can choose to share that with
whoever individuals corporations how I
choose and when I choose but I own this
data and this is really just the more I
input the more the system can better
output and serve me yeah
we get oh yeah we have this suite also
show here's this one - yeah this one's
this one's fun so we talked about it
it's just a fun visual and this this
really starts to elucidate what you're
seeing here is on the screen a
matchmaking between two human beings and
it's showing them what quests they're
actively on together so where are places
they can partner together and quest into
something together and then what is in
this case what would be what is james
offering the greatest support it like in
this case we have Shannon and James so
what can James offer Shannon that's most
aligned and what can Shannon offer when
we throw it on Emmy - quick so we can
see this one - thank you so so Shannon
can offer what can Shannon offer James
what can James offer Shannon what can
they so this is showing all their
alignment points on a screen whether
this gets real and this is again
asynchronous and synchronous if you're
choosing to play with geo proximal
functionality which you can turn off and
off at any time this could have been a
conversation sparked at a gas pump where
it's like hey we have 80% alignment and
I can immediately see what keys you hold
for me and what keys I hold for you I'm
looking for you actually can be a mentor
to me in two things I'm looking for
mentorship in yeah and I've got
something for you so that's on a screen
but then this graphic kind of shows you
it kind of gives you a visual picture
because we're not going to go into the
whole not into the whole visual deck of
the AR componentry of yes because that's
down the road but it gives you an idea
of what it would look like to first on a
screen but much more importantly with
where this is really the first to me
real social benefit application of AR
people have been really trying to push
AR and a lot of its in the gaming world
and it doesn't really have much social
benefit value where it currently is
she's tough to parse by geolocation and
just the unique identifiers zuv you know
Allen is currently in this location and
Joyce is in this location and they're
coming together oh well there's a high
proximity person that has a high
alignment and you can embark on these
quests together I was mentioning this to
you earlier but who
be interesting to know what what
gene-culture co-evolution how this is
actually affect us because so much of
our cognition is used for identifying
the fact that joyous is this specific
person and I I asked questions to get to
know you right and your North Star and
like to see how much alignment you have
intended to see if we should correct but
then if all that cognitive power and
genetic evolution goes out the window
because I don't need to do it anymore
but now I just see think this is all the
stuff about you then we go right into
playing the playing great so it's
disaster to get there which is
interesting I just wonder then how that
ends up affecting our actual biological
evolution that's that that gene-culture
co-evolution severe no it's just a cool
I think that I know think it's the date
you know it's a very and and with
anything with any technology because
it's rap it technologies drastically
changed the ways and we could pop off
this if we want okay cool yeah sounds
good it's it's drastically changed the
ways that we have that we relate you
know I mean we don't have to retain
information where Google has it I mean
people I don't remember foe people who
remembers phone numbers anymore so it is
interesting we are letting go of things
we are handing things off and that is
again the emergence of new consciousness
and who knows if it's good or bad it's
like any technology we're on Damocles
blade to me to me the benefit outweighs
the risk in terms of removing the the I
mean when you imagine you go to an event
and you and I bump into each other and
maybe we're like most people and we're
just we're drinking a little bit so we
can like feel safe interacting I mean I
don't think you drink and I don't but
anyway like a normal person we're like
okay I got a like okay I feel safe I
feel loose to talk to people maybe the
normal person doesn't do that to feel
loose to talk to be well maybe they
don't yeah maybe they don't I don't know
why they would I mean yeah you know
that's a it's good that just a thought
from my when I was when I was drinking
when I was younger it certainly helped
me in social settings just be like it
was like lubrication but still then it's
like okay who are you are you from what
do you do
there's some very generic questions what
do you do and I don't really care about
that I'm more care about who are you
wait your what is your North Star what
inspires you most yeah what's your core
purpose while you're on the planet I ask
my over drivers asking everyone likewise
yeah everyone right away so imagine just
going to that right away yes right
and then taking out the like we're two
kids in a sandbox and we're kind of like
feeling each other out so just right
away like wow okay I chose to set my
sensitivity to I only want to see people
80% of lines or I only want to see
people aligned to mine to my what I've
defined is my current North Star that
I'm developing in the system because
there's you know some define your core
purpose and then have things attached to
that different quests attached to that
so I can set the metrics for what I'm
looking for but immediately be able to
find I'm in an event there's a thousand
people may only be three or four people
that are super relevant to me and so
just to have the ability to turn that on
turn that on and then be alerted that
and what and you have to have your zone
to for that to work yeah we have both
have to say we want to be findable here
too right that's security and safety the
process more effective and it's
synchronicity yeah you can get right to
the chase if I know that you and I share
a similar North Star and I can also see
how I could potentially support you in
your life and you in mind immediately we
can go into deeper connection into
collaboration to creativity instead of
spending hours days maybe weeks maybe
months parsing out what we can look just
get right away to read out like okay
great
we're really aligned how do we want to
play let's get to know each other yeah
and then what is we our thing great yeah
so we are as the parent of I am we are
as the larger consciousness right
ultimately that's the vibration we're
working toward yet if you think about
the universe as you know if you break
that down into what it mean the
universe one verse one song it's one
song with all these infinite myriad of
notes and tones within it we each hold a
unique organic signature each tone or
frequency if I haven't been connected to
my I am and I'm trying to play and I'm
trying to be the trombone player in the
universe but I'm really a drum player
what does that do to the rest of the
universe through the symphony so we
realized you know we are we are as a
broader a broader
tanner it's designed to be a new
paradigm incubator and management
company model that takes some of the
best practices like if you look at what
Google did with okay everyone you get
Friday to just create create anything
related to your passions as long as it's
related to like your skills and you know
kind of how you show up but free-range
crit you're gonna get paid to create
your some of their best products that
come from that so you can take with
Google and Zappos some of these some of
these companies have kind of paved the
way for how to innovate and and and
allow more openness and creativity in
the workplace and then we have some some
things we won't dive into on the show
but really looking at how do we evolve
the cultural parameters of holding a
company so we are is going to really a
big focus for it is is what is the
culture that we're looking to engender
as a company how do we model that how do
we model that for the companies we
incubate how do we model that for the
shareholders or the investors who are
coming in the social impact investors to
support these companies and so we are
it's kind of ethos is to redefine our
world is to redefine how how business
operates and it's an Inc fundamentally
an incubator and management company for
evolved enterprises and its first
flagship of all the enterprise as I am
so the I am we are is kind of the
continuum of like let's connect the
world billions of people to their I am
let's connect them to their full value
give them a sovereign interface to
proclaim that to embody that to develop
that to actualize and monetize that and
then we can invite them into we are so
we're actually thinking about
cultivating sponsorships and
entrepreneurs people are really coming
online and really lighting up and
stepping in there I am being able to
help incubate some of the the
enterprises that are coming out of those
individuals through we are and of course
other companies as well but that's
that's really the framework yeah damn I
love divisions with we are as well it's
almost as though like there's all these
good codes or good protocols that exist
within some of the most especially New
Age organizations that then if could get
synthesized into a new paradigm like a
spiritual workplace of I am errs that
are all
pursuing their North Stars Plus
co-creating I love it I'm yeah I'm I'm
huge I'm huge on this this is so much on
the on that principle of know thyself
and socialize it and know ourselves as a
we as well okay let's wrap with a couple
thoughts perfect we good on yeah
oh great yeah yeah okay I'm gonna go
through any other like portals or
dimensional hops you can take us on this
next dimensionals portal hop or we in a
simulation absolutely 100% that's my
belief
we can only share perspectives and
beliefs you know scientifically like if
you look at like how we've gone all the
way in past the quark like plank like
the the deepest we've gotten in its all
pixels it's all pixels okay like we're
inside of a simulation or inside of a
hologram I consider the universe a
quasicrystal of consciousness it's it it
has a energetic matrix that's geometries
and sound and then those get so
infinitely intricately layered that they
become reality in the actualities
escapes and we really believe it it's
amazing like we really believe in this
in the game and we want to because
that's how we we and the me that's
playing get to evolve and know ourselves
and continue to expand the universe the
universe is you know I say from my
direct experience where I could say in
periods that we're in a simulation
through some of the experiences that had
like the nd I shared with you earlier
they really showed me that you know this
this is a holographic reality that our
consciousness from my belief and our our
patterning translates from Avatar to
avatar right like oh crap I die in the
game reset that's what happens here it's
like taking your clothes off yet we
carry it forward which is why it's
really important to be you know there's
people like the Dalai Lama that they
reincarnate through cycles and then the
other you know Tibetan Lamas they're
going around looking
for they know they know that being when
they find them like okay you're five we
got to tell you this is what you've been
in the last fifteen incarnations so it's
really important to realize or to begin
to play with the idea that there is more
than this lifetime there is something
beyond death right and realize that
whatever you do here translates forward
and so in the simulation even if I'm
like I'm gonna turn that screen off it
doesn't matter because it's playing in
all these other screens and so yes I
believe in a simulation which is I think
really fun when you can when you can
acknowledge that because you don't have
to take it so seriously it is serious
and it's also playful and light and you
know oh my god turn into a screen at any
time you make if you choose to turn one
off
yeah I'm really trying to get down to
that that quark and Planck length and
see that pixelation and then also get
how that is quasi crystal in this making
this stuff I'm trying to get that we had
clear when I show I'm trying to get I'm
Garrett Lisi I'm trying to get her into
yeah I'm into what they're you know the
theories are like Michio Kaku these are
very interesting like what is going on
at that such a small linked and how is
that making these items in and then what
is source creating that doesn't process
and I love that and we'll we can dive
yeah deeper into this s our next
conversations that I gained more
standing of the subject well we could
have a whole show just that's actually I
love it okay this is this is gonna be
the Silicon Valley stopped for you guys
there's so much just to talk about they
come back and visit more I love it yeah
it kind of goes without saying that then
that you believe that the processes that
we come from source into these bodies to
to learn these lessons in the school of
earth yeah and to express our own
creative potential or no we're stars
that's kind of your yeah not processor
yeah and life as the school love is the
lesson so what do you love really what
do you love attune to that that that is
teaching you how to be in alignment with
your North Star life is the school love
is it a lesson yeah what do you look for
lesson yeah what do you love who are you
what do you what are you choosing to
become you know what is that if you
really think about what lights you up
most what brings you most alive what you
love tune into that dive more into that
subscribe more to that because that's
pointing you toward your North Star and
the reason that you're here because you
have a unique mission generally there's
all lots of subsets to it but you have a
purpose for being here everyone does and
and it's a great gift when you tap into
it and choice what is the most beautiful
thing in the world the most beautiful
thing in the world so many myriad
answers come to mind when you ask that
question life life is beautiful it's an
exquisite experience human life
particularly is beautiful it's it's
everything it's like it's raw it can be
can be and it's beautiful what we get to
feel and experience is freakin beautiful
and it's unique from what I've
experienced in having encounters with
other types of intelligence and from NDS
and other ways of leaving the body it's
really in the accumulate
very few species in the cosmos can feel
like we do well they don't have that
spectrum I think that that is something
that's that's extremely beautiful yeah
the spectrum of emotion and feeling
potentials on this on this planet as a
human species is of the most
sought-after yeah I was gonna keep it I
was gonna you know I was gonna follow my
beloved and and say my family my
children cuz that's true yeah
but really when I look at on a meta
level it humanities beautiful it's all
of it and it's beautiful and this life
this experience is really beautiful and
specifically in this moment in this time
the amount of courageous bold audacious
souls who are choosing to align it in
our star and what that's creating in
terms of a social planetary
transformation ripple effect that's
freaking beautiful yeah like the worse
it gets the better it gets great like
there's all kinds of crazy [ __ ]
happening on this planet right now great
because on the contrast it's so
beautiful like yeah the level of
breakthrough and transcendence that we
are on the tipping point up and we get
to be creators of because we're all like
we're actively co-creating it you can
choose to just sit there and be dormant
and subscribe to what everyone else is
creating more you can actually step in
and say I'm creator playing through this
lens this is who I am and the more
people I see doing that and all the
really inspired projects and
collaborations that are coming out out
of the space everywhere I look that's
beautiful the Ascension of consciousness
here yeah
while Joyce holy cow I feel so good I
feel as though you are have such an
important role an important key you and
what you're making because the endeavor
to the North Star to have that process
be socialized and fun gamified and
exciting and leverage cutting-edge
technology to do it around the world I
love it I'm good job thank you keep up
thank you let's play let's play yeah
this is a global project we're calling
in you and every other co-creator who
feels inspired in any way to bring
forward that technology framework and
the consciousness behind it to the world
so thank you for everything you're doing
with this show for bringing together
some of the greatest and most inspired
minds on the planet for a line with
their North Star and may we and we
support these types of technologies that
are coming through I'm just a steward
for what what I am is may we support and
empower each other all over each other
let's hold each other's hands and walk
each other home thank you thank you so
much you thank such a pleasure watch
more co-creation I'm so pumped and
everyone thank you so much for tuning in
we greatly appreciate it we'd love to
hear your thoughts in the comments below
let's know what you're thinking go have
more conversation with your friends your
families co-workers people online on
social media about things like I am
about self-actualization technologies
have more conversations about this talk
more about what your North Stars what
other people's North Stars are making
that a more frequent conversation on
this personal space yes please and check
out the links in the bio to play I am
calm also I am we are dot X Y Z I am
joyous dot X Y Z and also Joyce's
Instagram and Facebook profiles
shoutouts you Ori Shapiro for producing
thank you very much Ori and also support
the artists the entrepreneurs the
organizations the spiritual leaders
around the world that you believe and
support them help them grow support
simulation our links are below as well
our patreon PayPal links down there
or cryptocurrency linked and all seeking
design cool merch and get paid help
support us help us grow and go and build
the future everyone manifest your dreams
into the world we love you very much
thank you for tuning in we'll see you
soon